[Music]
mine's a little off
it was about as good as last time so as
long as i can see the big line
then we can uh head that through okay
good
all right hello listener you are
listening to the pill pod
the only auntie applebee's podcast
on the internet where you can hang with
us and dose yourself on critical theory
philosophy
and whatever other eccentricities come
up
the pillpot are a bunch of doctors or
almost doctors of philosophy
midwives of the soul some may call us
anyway
we're kicking back with some beers
whoa you didn't tell me that was
happening oh well you missed out
books and we're gonna discuss what's the
theme today conspiracy
theory indeed um today you have the
regular four of us
as well as guest matthew
mcmanus what's up matthew mcmanus is one
of the most productive people
judging by his facebook because on
twitter
you know what's interesting about matt
is he's the most charitable
guy you've ever seen dealing with the
most absurd arguments on
facebook let alone twitter but if you
judge by his facebook he's willing to
have a three-hour argument with a
zionist
yeah and the zionist you know has a
picture of himself at some tourist site
and his
wife is next to him looking very scared
excellent what what zines did you debate
with for three hours
oh it's some person i knew from back in
my undergraduate degree
we've never actually spoken in person
more than once or twice but for some odd
reason he
has this interest in what i'm doing and
he's been arguing with me for
years and years and years not really i
don't know if there's a word for this
but it's an
anti-fan it's the the person who's just
sitting urgently waiting for the
notification that matt has posted
something and then as soon as he does
he'll verbally assault him troll
there's a few of them now actually i
feel like you have a lot of those i have
like
professional trolls yeah i don't know if
i have any fans i definitely have trolls
who are like active and commenting on
whatever the [ __ ] i'm doing pretty
much yeah pretty solid troll base you
can always expect
i would say that's true i mean basically
i
have a bunch of different conspiracies
uh on why it is that these people are
interested
in doing this some of them i think are
just trying to annoy me but other people
i think
get a sense of indication from these
kind of disputes especially because
some of the people who comment on my
facebook are
reasonably like intellectually savvy
right people like you
other phds and i think being included in
that group
gives them a sense of accomplishment at
the very least
so just for the sake of our listeners
matt mcmanus is an
academic and an author his main arena
is post-modern conservatism where he
accuses conservatives of doing the
things that they accused the left of
doing
mainly invoking conservatism and
a lack of universal truth and so on matt
do you want to say anything
else about that sure well the basis of
my argument and
you are all familiar with it right is
that post-modern culture isn't
necessarily something that just sprung
from the pens of a couple of eccentric
french
authors in the 1960s you know it's a
cultural condition
uh that's generated by a lot of profound
transformations that have been going on
in our society for the last
couple centuries really and since it's a
cultural condition you shouldn't just
expect that there's going to be
a postmodern left politics you expect it
to be
much more ubiquitous than that and my
argument is that people like trump or
victor orban
or jair bolsonaro and brazil are the
products of post-modern culture
hence what i call post-modern
conservatives you could call it a
conspiracy theory
which is the reason that we invited him
on today
so uh to kick this off we have usually
based
our discussions on this podcast around a
specific
reading we're trying something different
today in basing it around a
topic because we all have our own
areas of expertise in our degrees
and our areas of study so
my thought in introducing a topic
rather than a reading was we could all
bring our own
sort of interests to the discussion and
argue about what a conspiracy theory is
that way
so the first thing that i wanted to
bring up was that i think
um a conspiracy theory is a semiotic
that is sign based
structure conspiracy theories give
the entire world a meaning they sort of
index
every different aspect of the world and
particularly media events
into a sort of structure and i'm going
to argue that this structure is actually
coherent
it's it doesn't make sense to say that
conspiracy theories are false or at
least that's not the way that you should
argue against them
because simply by arguing that it's
false you're going to be
falling in to the indexes of their
conspiracy theory that says
you know you're on the sides of the
elites or whatever
um and it forms a coherent world view
are we on the sides of the league uh of
the elite no they're the
opponents to your rebuttal
to their theory then they will say oh
you've just been brainwashed
by the elites which is why you're
accepting
yeah i've been selling sheeple for
believing that covet is real
so yeah and that isn't it's worth
mentioning like kind of the whole the
whole the angle on the conspiracy theory
topic too is like
in the context of covid19 of course
right because there's a lot of them
these days and i think that's the reason
that we chose to do that
today is uh the conspiracy theory is
uh surrounding kovid i mean variously
either that kovid was created by
some malicious agent or that the
government is trying to
use kovid as a a means
of taking over the control of people's
individual freedoms and i want to first
before anyone else says it says anything
uh reference this back to bruno latour
who we discussed
earlier on the podcast of the first two
episodes
and he basically says that critical
theory
bears exactly the same structure as
conspiracy theory
so we can both defend critical theory
which is something that we're all
engaged in at the same time as
you know distancing ourselves from these
uh local views of the world or paradigms
for interpreting the world and
clearly he has a very particular way he
wants critical theory to be done
and so it's more so resembles conspiracy
theory when it's not done
right eric do you want to elaborate
first of all just on
what he's saying when he claims that
critical theory
bears resemblance to a conspiracy theory
yeah you can pause as long as you want
sorry i'm getting some audio
difficulties here
yeah uh well bruno latour's
uh argument against critical
theory is essentially that
um when people when people look at the
world
in terms of uh what he calls the
modernist settlement
uh which is basically this this
cultural phenomenon in which we hold
opposing concepts contradictory concepts
uh together uh
but we find a way to um resolve that
conflict
and look at the world through this lens
of these contradictory concepts at the
same time
so you have things like subject objects
nature culture
um and and usually the moves in your
argument are to be like oh well your
your view of the world is dominated by
ideology so listen to me
because i have the real picture
of what was going on in the world and
then
the next argument is that when somebody
thinks they they do see the world
clearly they just say uh
you're not seeing things clearly i mean
it's it's a complex argument but
basically conspiracy theory has the same
general structure as
badly done critical theory so just to
summarize you could say it's something
like you're interpreting
this phenomena and this
is phenomena sign for something bigger
going on behind the scenes would that
make sense to say
sure yeah you you project i mean the
conspiracy theory
thing is you project some kind of unity
or some kind of agency onto
negative things that are happening in
the world and
and either it's a result of the
government or some other organization
behind the scenes and honestly a lot of
critical theory looks like that too you
know you have foucault talking about
power for instance
that's that can be construed as a
conspiracy theory
or even or even what agambin was talking
about uh the last
couple uh episodes yeah maybe we'll get
into some kind of leftist conspiracy
theory but but i think generally we'll
be uh restricted to the right
but not necessarily you can even talk
about something like media theory right
manufacturing consent and the idea that
the media are all part of some elite
organization that are ultimately been
unconsciously putting
a conformist agenda on the broader
population yeah
exactly just for the sake of giving
concrete examples and i don't want to
be disparaging any of these disciplines
but the easiest way to break it down
would be to say
something like the different branches of
critical theory so
neo-marxism projects this enemy
called capitalism and they
attribute a number of malicious things
that happen in the world
to capitalism or feminism
would call it the patriarchy or
i don't know gender studies would call
it heteronormativity
so these the their axioms against
which you posit your own research and
your own views
as this normative status quo that you
are standing in opposition to and i
don't think bruno latour called out any
of those things specifically
i'm only trying to provide a map here
for the kinds of things that he might be
talking about so it's
the big bad enemy that's behind
every local thing that you interpret
i wonder um to what extent that
definition
also maps on to like populism
because the way you're describing that
reminds me a lot of
like sort of textbook definitions of
populism where you have like
it's like very there's an oppositional
structure right where you have
like the fake people who are trying to
get in your way of like the truth or the
authentic
potential in uh in the population
and then of course you have like the
real people that this populist leader is
trying to
fight for and there's maybe some sort of
inherently
built in conspiratorial thinking into
populist thinking i wonder if you guys
would agree
follow the same structure for sure
the same method of argument is often
used
to support your beliefs in conspiracy
theory
right it's um or conspiracy theories are
like a vehicle
that or like a a a kind of yeah like a
tactic for populism maybe
i think that's true i think that what
distinguishes populist conspiracies here
arising from
the more standard variants that we see
is the fact that populism spiritually
theorizing
heavily over-determined uh from a
psychological standpoint
and so you see more extreme iterations
of the similar dynamic that you were
talking about
that's where i think it's a bit
different but fundamentally i think that
yeah it's
pretty similar yeah yeah and and latour
emphasizes the
the speed at which conspiracy theories
are
are emerging today after the event right
i mean you have a major event that
latour refers to
as 9 11. we're going to talk maybe a bit
about kovid
but it's really the the dust of the
event has barely settled before
a multiplicity of conspiracy theories
emerge
and they all purport to explain exactly
what is really going on right there's
this kind of
link to this sort of truth truth or kind
of
kind of tendency behind it is to say
this this is what
it looks like is happening but this is
what's really going on and if you
know what i know then you can get by a
little bit better in the world
it's not just if you know what i know
it's if you just make the right
connections
which we can all do and that's what the
conspiracy theorist is telling us that
this knowledge is available to everyone
and it's based on
how many different things come into play
that cannot possibly
be coincidence cannot be accidental
and always have some lurking i'm going
to use the term
other behind the scenes that is
controlling everything and
pulling strings yeah i mean the way that
i understand this and
is that a conspiracy theorist and i'll
jump off what you were saying here
because i think it's
broadly correct uh is ultimately like a
kind of
pseudo optimist rationalist right where
everything in the world is super
saturated with meaning the mind can
comprehend it
and all we need to do is
untangle the human barriers to our
understanding uh imposed by power
and the universe will become fully
comprehensible
and this is ultimately a very optimistic
view in my standpoint because
there's this belief that anything that
goes on in the world is ultimately the
result of some human power
uh that's pulling the strings and all we
need to do of course or reptile aliens
or the reptile aliens yeah some
conscious being the sense that the
universe is ultimately
catastrophic in and of itself and
sometimes bad things just happen
is it something that can really be
incorporated into the conspiracy
theorist world view because of course if
things just happen
that means nobody's actually willing
them to be uh they just occur
because of nature uh which is inherently
non-anthropo
entropic and therefore are inherently
beyond our control or at least beyond
our full control
right and kovit's the perfect example of
that right because they don't want to
accept that
it just happened that just this virus
emerged in whatever a wet market in
china or who knows where and
it's just blind luckily mutated and
jumped to humans and like that's
something that they don't want to know
i'm wondering if like times person of
the year will be like man who ate bat in
wuhan market you know
i mean so the point of this is that we
can invoke
our patron of this podcast
dr jordan b peterson it's an antidote to
chaos
so we have this structure and even even
if the actors
in our narrative are malicious at least
they make sense of the world
for us but i want to jump to a word that
i think will get us
pretty far in this discussion that matt
said
a little while ago which is over
determining so over determining
has to do with causation and
conspiracy theory is fundamentally about
over-determining
phenomena which is ascribing too much
agency
to a particular origin or
intention behind an event that occurs
so whatever event it is it really
doesn't matter they're usually media
events but
moon landing 911 covid
most recently and about over determining
the causes that go into that
my question to the crowd then is
what is being over determined and would
there be a correct way
to interpret these events without over
over determining it
considering the fact that in our
lives just our existential day-to-day
watching tv looking at the internet
lives we have to deal with so much
information
because my perspective on this is
conspiracy theories
make sense in a in a very literal
interpretation of that sentence they
make sense of an extremely complicated
world
by over determining anything that looks
random as something intentional
yeah i mean i'll talk about my favorite
filmmaker dinesh d'souza
uh and his latest movies hillary's
america um
donald trump you know and his new stuff
about the
nation because one of the things that's
interesting is exactly how he over
determines
the significance of the democratic party
and the significance it's played in
apparently leading to this decline of
american power
and real americans over the last 40 or
50 years
and it's extraordinarily simplistic
narrative right that
any kind of problems that you speaking
to the quote real people
uh detect in your society right now it's
the fault of the democratic party
and most of us would look at the
democratic party today and say
this is one of the most poorly run
political institutions in the world they
don't see
know what they're doing uh you know what
the hell are they thinking
uh and by us as probably the more
literal truth and the same as
to certainly said through the republican
party but by over determining
uh this one political party and
streamlining this very simplistic
narrative about decline
into one where these malicious actors
are responsible for all the bad things
that have happened to you
it allows people to retreat from the
complexity of the world
into the cinema uh where there's an
antagonist uh and themselves who are
ultimately the protagonist in the story
to
rebuild the nation from the ground up
that's my thought about it at least
or at least one example we can re we can
reconnect this to
what alex who is psychoanalysis guy
just said um this is all about
creating another and even over
determining
another from which you can get your
identity right
i think this gives us a really clear and
almost too easy example about how
uh when we're talking about the other uh
and when lacan introduced
the object to petite and the small
the small other and the big other
they're so inter-related
they almost cannot be discussed without
each other
and so when he talks about the small
other he's talking about that
fundamental
fantasy that is i mean imagine how when
like
we have desire for like even like an
image of another that
image is internal to our psyche
um we could say that you know the cause
of desire the fundamental fantasy of the
conspiracy
theory has an inextricable relation
to both law and the body and it posits
another that is so imaginary that it
doesn't even have an
image attached to it unless we're
talking about
you know lab coats big pharma and lizard
people
and so we have all these images come to
mind that are just so
fantasmatic um but uh i think the
relation to
law is crucial um we could think of
conspiracy theories in terms of you know
i mean i think there once would have
been a time where
um talking about all the phenomena that
resulted in the me too movement would
have been like okay there's no way
that's all true that's a conspiracy
theory
but hey we could really investigate
these things and say
okay there's some really horrible things
going on
totally institutionalized and
really look into them but what makes
conspiracy theory different is
we have it's just totally powers of the
imagination it's like literature that
posits itself
as real it's fantasmatic and it's
internal to the psyche of the subject
who is looking for other people to
validate that fantasy
although doesn't it doesn't it depend
somewhat on like taking
something verifiable and then like
extending it beyond
like reasonableness of conclusions um
and i think like one other link i like
to add on to that is
related to what matt was talking about
which is the way in which
uh conspiracy theories write it's like
about wanting to avoid
uh it's like an optimistic i really like
that by the way that it's like
that there's like an optimism to it
built into conspiracy theories
yeah you could connect this to the
psychoanalytic point because in some
ways like what is the subject
trying to do with the conspiracy theory
but i think like tr like in a way
attempting to avoid like the real
of of this kind of of just the blind
like the fact that things just happen
and like that's it's like in some ways
conspiracy theories
maybe you'll disagree this is why i love
the pill pod
because where there's a a theory of
conspiracy theory
emerging just out of this discussion
while we bounce off of each other
so to push this a little bit further
dealing with all these events
and we have these over determined signs
whatever they are
in context you know kovid kovid
is an event created by 5g
to bring about some malthusian
population control or whatever the
theory is
but we get these over determined signs
and then we get enclosed universes of
conversation
so if you deny the conspiracy theory
to a conspiracy theorist then you
are taking the side of the elites
against them so the other
that remains part of the narrative and
the other from which
you're gaining your own identity
and that's i like what you said alex
that it's almost a two
easy example of this occurring
now what i like to look at though is
how psychoanalysis is looking at
unconscious
laws the superego is
often thought to be made up of laws and
we we can't emphasize enough how these
are often
unspoken laws i think a way to look at
this
in terms of conspiracy theories is not
just
unconscious laws but the structure of
law our fundamental fantasy is a
relation
to the structure of law
and it's very bodily we're being told
what to do with our bodies we're being
very
uh much i think we lost him
oh he's
lost to ko he's he's he knows too much
and uh i think they sent someone over to
his house to uh
take him out probably from the from the
gates foundation
the kovids took him out the bill and
melinda's
they're based on anxieties about
the body but they're based on structures
of law
as well being told what to do being told
what to put in our bodies
being told what bodies to be frightful
of
and so this is a way of looking at how
our fundamental fantasy is related to
the big other and so it posits a brand
new big other that doesn't even
exist i mean we can't find these people
pulling the strings
that are creating covid as
either a hoax or that are using it for
their advantages
that are using cell towers to control
our bodies
or our minds it all has to be posited
uh as some other
that is beyond the law it gives us a new
entitled relation to the law and that's
where identity
comes into it but if you're going to
take lacan seriously that's not
like or that's not a conspiracy theory
that does that that's just the way we
have to
function in order to relate to others in
the first place
so is our life a conspiracy theory could
you say that
no but we can he did say
very clearly and he's very rarely clear
he said very clearly
that the paranoiac has fantasies that
follow the same structure
as the neurotics fantasies so we are all
doing this
regularly we are all positing an idea of
what the other wants from us we all have
fantasies that we impose on
the external world um
so to an extent it follows the same
structure and i think this
gets us to the crux wait is there a
did he cut out again yeah he cut out
again i think his internet connection is
really shitty it's
a it's a dramatic it's a dramatic pause
all right so to move on from this
dramatic pause
we have now dealt with conspiracy theory
in the politics and conspiracy theory
and psychoanalysis so i want to move to
our last
guy that we haven't dealt with eric who
is
semiotics guy what would
conspiracy theory look like if you
analyzed it from a semiotic
perspective so i'll just give you a
jumping point here
a semiotic structure it studies
signs and references and a lot of
semiotics is trying to determine
whether or not words represent reality
or not quote unquote but in the case of
conspiracy theory the whole system is
like self-referential so whether or not
the conspiracy
theory turns out to be true doesn't
really matter so as far as the semiotic
system is concerned everything that
counts
as relevant as a sign refers
to another part of that system so uh
eric as semiotics guy
how would you interpret a conspiracy
theory and a sign
like the event of covid
as a semiotic structure i mean i guess
i'll just start by
saying that i mean there's
there's a couple different reasons that
a bunch of people would come together
who don't really believe in conspiracy
theories
to come together to talk about them
because why would we
want to talk about conspiracy theories i
mean on the one hand
many of them are completely innocuous
they are not very harmful uh and others
not so much i mean we've seen people
burning
uh 5g towers as a result of the beliefs
that it's causing covid or it's or
break some kind of plan
to uh to manage the population in some
other way
sorry my computer just uh ran out of
battery and then
stopped so i had to get the charger
again my bad
eric's in the middle of a point oh sorry
well i mean i'm just thinking about why
like
before we get to the semiotic
perspective it's good to think about why
would we
want to even talk about what like what's
the point of engaging
with with people who believe in
conspiracy theories because
because on the one hand some of them are
pretty innocuous
and on the other hand some of them can
actually be quite dangerous
and have negative effects especially in
places where
people uh don't have access to the sorts
of information that we have access to
right i mean i remember
i remember when i was first saw the
sort of 5g conspiracies linked to the
emergence of covid and i thought
immediately that these
this is just [ __ ] like i i feel like
i can spot a conspiracy theory when i
see one
and lo and behold the 5g conspiracy
theory
right so from
from the from the semiotic perspective
that i
look at i mean the answer to like
any conspiracy theory i guess it depends
on the conspiracy
because when we're trying to look at
something like kovid right
it's that's a natural phenomenon and it
has
but it but it is largely a result of
human
activity and
something like 911 is more of a social
phenomenon we could safely say
and it has more to do with the
geopolitical landscape of the planet
right so
from a semiotic perspective those
distinctions are going to be important
so it's it's not so easy to just sort of
talk about
the general structure of a conspiracy
from a semiotic perspective
because you have to know what the event
what how are we characterizing the
events that the conspiracy theories are
purporting to explain in the first place
that's that's one important thing to
establish so something like kovid right
the truth behind the event is that we
have to wait
because we don't know what it is we
don't know what it's going to do
we don't know what the future is going
to hold for kovid
so right now the conspiracy theories are
that that you you already described in
the best way it's a closed
self-referential universe that has less
to do with the actual event and more to
do with the people involved
the people who are looking for answers
the people who
have existential difficulties and
they're looking for some sort of
affirmation
or they're looking to be a part of some
kind of social group
and repeating these conspiracy theories
and learning about them as a way to feel
like you're a part of something and so
in a way they have nothing to do with
the event themselves
so it's a little difficult i'd have to
think about a little more about it in
terms of
covid specifically if we want to get
into that more
as the podcast goes on well one thing
that i want to bring back
though is the conspiracy theories that
we
watch never have to do with particular
events
that you know happen on your lawn
they're always about
the broadest sort of media events
the moon landing where everyone's glued
to their tv watching
i don't know neil armstrong do whatever
or 911
where everyone's glued to their tv
watching the towers collapse
so i would say that the sign is not
actually the event itself the sign
is the media event and this is me
bringing in bojar
the conspiracy theory is there's more
that meets the eye
especially in terms of the way that the
media reports on it
because the conspiracy theorist is the
least likely person to trust
the media is reporting on an event
right i'm tempted to say so much on it
too
along those lines that yes what what the
conspiracy theories are designed to meet
is not the event itself but more like an
image right because what the media does
when we say a simulation sure
yeah we could say that we could say that
it is a simulacrum
um i mean i'm not i'm not in that
tradition of semiotics but we don't need
to go into that but
really what the media does is it
constructs an image for you right the
moon landing
people have a very visual imagistic
sense of that
same with you know the the twin towers
collapsing we all
i mean those of us who are old enough to
remember it have a very
specific sort of image in our minds of
what happened and that kovit even like
covid has an
image right we have those those those
little uh those little what
viruses look like those are paraded
around
on the online all this so they're meant
to meet the image
and not really the reality behind the
image because especially in terms of
covid that's
that's going to be the job of scientists
to study and
figure out what the hell's going on
there but really what it means is the
is the simulacrum the the the media
constructed image that then begins to
circulate that people then
connect in various ways and that's what
what
indexing something can mean in that
sense is that it the reference
of this i mean you see the same sort of
conspiracy pop-up for each thing right
say 9 11 covid's whatever you want they
there's either some kind of um
[Music]
cia plot you know liberal elites
i mean each time the structure is the
same but they're connected to different
images so that's how they're indexed
like those
explanations are ready there in the
background in the sense those are the
things doing the over
determining and then what is being over
determined
is the event the image the simulacrum
itself
because it just becomes fodder for
further unfolding this world view
rather than actually explaining anything
that's going on in the world in any
genuine kind of way right
in a literal and figurative way this is
do not believe your eyes and i think
we should unpack this further maybe
later on down the road but it's very
much a visual phenomenon because they
take a
they look at a picture of the earth
from the moon and say look there's like
uh artifacts in the jpeg image
that show that this was probably
photoshopped even though it was like
taken in 1960 or whatever so it's do not
believe your eyes
right and in the semiotic tradition
again
i mean not in the one i'm working from
symbol has a very different meaning in
the one i'm working in but
when i'm saying image i'm also talking
about a symbol because what a symbol
generally is is the meaning is assigned
to a symbol right it's a convention it's
understood to be true
therefore that's the reference of the
symbol
so when you you can take whatever image
you want
the tower is falling down so that
becomes a symbol
for various explanations that and those
explanations are the point
it's not the event itself being
explained it's the explanation that's
the point
and so when we the same goes for things
like
dog whistles right when we talk about oh
that word is just
is a alt-right dog whistle right that's
because the word
itself whatever the word is is meaning
or explaining
in its original sense doesn't matter
because it's the symbol
the symbol is a conventional thing that
people
assign meaning to they they grow they
gain meaning they change meaning
and so when i say image i'm sort of
meaning the same thing and lacan
is very much in that tradition where
symbol means
what is agreed in the community
that uses that symbol and this is where
critical theory
what most of us do all of us are
inspired by at least
and conspiracy theory are cousins
because there's
always more referenced by the sign
that can't be seen by the untrained eye
until your eye is trained so when people
say
capitalism does this or that it's a
conspiracy theory
because it's applying a lot of volition
to these unintentional
forces capitalism is not this giant
lizard
behind the scenes so we could have a
long discussion about what counts as
intention or not
but whether it's elites politicians the
media
or some other sort of power relations
this conspiracy
instinct as well i think as the
critical instinct is that you shouldn't
trust the narrative that you're given
because there's always more that meets
the eye
so the narrative is sort of a system of
signs
that points to some outside
intention or other intention well this
is actually a point where i'd like to
talk about
bojar because i think beaujolais makes a
very subtle point
on this instance people have been
actually oversaturating various objects
and various symbols with meaning
for many centuries right you can think
of transubstantiation
in the catholic tradition where a piece
of bread wasn't just a piece of bread it
was meant to be the body of literal god
uh there in the room which you consume
and therefore
transcend your earthly quail and become
a part of god right
uh and what i think we see with people
who
look at images on tv and this hyper real
medium
is something very similar to what
dogmatists would see
uh when they're approaching the subject
of transubstantiation it can't just even
be
this image because most of us are savvy
right now to distrust
what we're shown uh there has to be some
deeper significance behind the image
you know this real thing that over
determines everything that's going on
and that provides what i'm seeing right
now with meaning and significance beyond
just
the mundane images and sounds that i'm
encountering
and i think this is fundamentally not a
critical attitude it looks critical
because it's skeptical of the fact that
this image is all that there is but it's
not because of what it wants is for this
meaning to be
there to be more meaning to this image
going beyond it
and what a truly critical disposition
does is wean you off of this need
to find significance in the things
around you
and to force yourself to ask more
critically what it is that you think is
important in life
and i think adding to that we could also
say being critical is about accepting
indeterminacy uh instead of over
determination right we instead of always
needing to show
the exact determined
symbolic value of the words and images
were presented and say no this is
the real truth behind them part of being
critical
i think is showing that we can never say
the whole truth
about a narrative that is indeterminate
injection at this point right like
lacombe um famously
inverted uh dostoyevsky's famous
injunction right that
uh without god everything is com
permitted right and the paul said no
uh without god nothing is permitted
right you know there's no one who's
authorizing your action
and giving it a significance that goes
beyond yeah he says nothing is permitted
anymore yeah he's uh
he's taking that from saint paul
actually
yeah exactly and like what i think you
know we're
seeing in these kind of circumstances
right as a conspiracy theorist is
somebody who
has to have some kind of authorization
uh for their actions and for their
beliefs
it goes beyond what they prevent
centered conventionally
but it still is transcendent uh in the
sense of
never arising from their self and their
own critical analyses of the world
all right so i like this because at
least we're drawing a differentiation
between
critical theory and conspiracy theory
you can't really use the words true or
false
to deal with either one of these things
it's rather more of a case of like
what is determining what because
conspiracy
theories are coherent and then good
theories
i is what i hear you guys saying good
theories of any kind
should be able to account for new
evidence yeah so when you recognize your
that truth is partially subjective you
should always be looking
for more instead of closing yourself off
absolutely i mean it's interesting when
you're saying that because i'm wondering
i'm thinking back to like a gambin's
covid19 antics and like i wonder if some
of what he says
falls into like the conspiracy in the
sense that it seems like he's not
like one of the mistakes he's making is
he's not just like taking the world in
like information in he already has this
framework that he wants to explain it
with and
i wonder if there's some parallel well i
agree that critical theory is not the
same as conspiracy theories of course
but i just like wonder whether
at least in this case a gambin is maybe
somehow falling into
this kind of vulnerability like it like
kind of determining
a kind of like infusing
uh what's happening in like the
governmental measures of
like against kovid with a kind of
significance that maybe isn't there
right that it's like about control and
it's about these things i don't know
what you guys think about it yeah i mean
i'd like to go back to the origins of
critical theory with socrates right and
say that
the first thing that's important in
being a critical theorist or critical
person genuinely
rather than being conspiracy theorists
is dispositional right it's an attitude
you take
even towards your own ideas uh and your
own
theoretical propositions which is
something socrates was always able to do
and i think what we're seeing here with
a genvin is somebody who developed this
very rich and interesting framework
but it's now become slightly dogmatic
it's something that he applies rotely to
every kind of situation
without interrogating its foundations or
its applicability
uh based on different kinds of evidence
right and i think that that demonstrates
that dispositionally
he's not really adopting a critical
standpoint any longer
at least in the sense that i think is
most important going back to this kind
of socratic orientation
i agree with that so could we say in
this
perspective then that both conspiracy
theory and critical theory
create semiotic universes but some are
large
and some are small and we're kind of
coming out on the side
of large universes that are willing to
interpret
new information and people characters
events
they all come to signify this new
universe
so the us versus them if it's small it's
not good if it's truth versus lie
which would be plato's interpretation of
this
or inside versus outside self versus
other
whatever it is but i'd be interested to
hear
alex's perspective on this because this
is precisely
delizi's critique of psychoanalysis
saying it's making a small universe
yeah so when dillas has so many even
performative critiques
of psychoanalysis um and so especially i
mean i guess the
typical one to go to would be the
edipolizing nature
of psychoanalysis that by constantly
telling us to question ourselves you
know it's putting us in a very specific
position that it wants to to further its
own goals
which we should be aware of um
so when you bring up deluz i mean so
what do you think dillas would say about
you know the way we're trying to
formulate
um what conspiracy theory is and how
we should look at it like how would he
critique our current discussion right
now you think
i don't think he'd critique it he like
all of schizophrenia and capitalism is
saying
the schizophrenic has a better view of
capitalism
than the rest of us do because we're
unable to see past it
the schizophrenic is at least able to
pull up these
worlds from other places from ground
zero in order to interpret the world in
a new way
whereas psychoanalysis is just
reinterpreting
the state by saying everything is mommy
daddy politics
yeah and i think this could bring us
back to it something i think we've
discussed
in previous episodes which is like when
we're constantly saying
oh you should be questioning your desire
it kind of gives the analyst the
privileged
position of seeming like they
aren't also coming from a place of
desire
we should recognize we are as well and
that when we are
you know critiquing theories and trying
to decide what is critical theory and
what is not
we are still positioned in terms of
fantasy somehow
um but i still think nonetheless you
know
this is a way of saying hey we are all
coming from a place of
fantasy uh and it gives us a way of i
think
opening up dialogue um
i mean when we're talking about like
discourse in terms of
large and small and we can bring in open
and
closed the more we recognize the
fantasmatic element
uh the more we can look at what is
presented to us in the media and whatnot
and at least say okay maybe they're
making mistakes in their
own subjective nature as creatures of
desire and fantasy
people who are trying to present
narratives to us
i mean instead of jumping on mistakes or
jumping on it and saying hey this is
entirely lies presented by this
other that i know about and nobody else
does and you should accept what i'm
saying about it
at least it gives us a way to you know
recognize we're dealing with something
that is
very hard to pin down and very
unpredictable uh
and i think this is the stance we should
be taking that's
cheesy
i would actually like here to kind of
make a different point which is to
insist on the psychoanalytic character
of the neurotic
in juxtaposition to the schizoid or the
schizo personality and delusion
guitarist theory
because it seems to me like the schizoid
personality
uh and de luz and qatari is somebody
who's really open to contingency in this
extraordinarily radical way
you know um operating from the
standpoint of this kind of bergsonian
approach to time
whereas the neurotic is somebody who
is trying to avoid contingency at all
costs by as we've all been pointing out
over determining the causes of their
existence
and all the things that happened to them
and so they're precisely somebody who's
very hostile to the idea of contingency
operating in their life
and is even willing to project um
various conspiratorial powers that
are operating in order to explain
whatever it is that's happening to them
i'm not sure what people delusion guitar
he never
discussed conspiracy theory specifically
that i can recall
but what's interesting what would be an
interesting question here is whether the
schizoid
or the neurotic is more likely to form a
conspiracy
theory because the schizoid just
believes
you know kind of everything to the point
of
your your mind is so open that it falls
out of the back your head
whereas the neurotic is so desperate to
project some sort of control
on becoming that it can't project
that they're gonna also make a
conspiracy theory
so i think it's interesting that you
just bust out the schizoid
um to this point because i don't i don't
yeah i don't know i don't know what
dillas would have to say about
conspiracy theories
beyond the fact that they're actually
nomadic and actually
departing from state philosophy and
state
structure i should probably say they're
just another
neurotic that should be more schizoid
right
yeah that's my feeling right you'd say
that you know
this can resemble the ideas um or sorry
resemble the schizoid personality
but because they're so hostile to
contingency uh it's not quite the same
right
i'm sure deleuze would have
liked conspiracy theories when he first
encountered them because he would see
them as
as lines of flight that resist capture
by institutionalized systems and then he
would grow as he did to hate ever
hate it eventually as he does to
everything because they would no longer
be
these free nomadic rhizomatic spreading
they would now be predicted and captured
by
institutional forces and arranged into
this sort of uh
orderly what does he call them this uh
this
this sort of consistent way of of
grabbing people's minds and
funneling their flows and their ver and
their potencies into these
systems of capture so you can see that i
mean you can see
for instance republican politicians
leaning into conspiracy theory now
because they know that they're going to
come out they know that
that some whack job somewhere is going
to come out with this conspiracy about
what's going
on and so they just get ahead of the
curve now and blame china right away
because because why not why we don't
have to uh we don't have to come up with
any genuine analysis we can just
rely on the neurotics to come forward
the neurotics who were trailblazers 20
years ago are now just
just captured by my you know
yeah i mean if you think about something
like alex jones he's kind of pedestrian
at this point right he's has his talking
points and he continuously comes back to
them
trump is almost always ahead of him
because he's got a new conspiracy theory
every week if i was alice jones i'd be
like
i can't [ __ ] keep up with you right
like you've got to like sing
like tone it down a little bit is the
chinese is it liberal elites is it
universities
yeah like when when kennedy when kennedy
was murdered i'm sure everyone was so
like so amped up on wow it was an inside
job and it was all planned and then 9 11
happens and
and then they come out the same [ __ ] it
was an inside job it was planned from
the start and by then everyone's like
i'm
tired of hearing this [ __ ] theory
about everything because it just plays
in
to what do you call it like the way that
there's a counter culture
and then there's a counter counter
culture and then that just becomes a
market group
i know one of my favorite videos i've
ever seen was actually somebody who
talked about how alex jones and other
911 truthers we're actually part of a
bigger conspiracy
in order to distract from the real
culprits response worlds within worlds
or some other group that never came out
exactly all right
so i'd like to move on from act two to
act
three in this discussion um
we can leave behind dillas unfortunately
and leave behind the high theory aspects
of this
and try to move into okay what does
or what is the function of conspiracy
theory
is it right is it wrong how does it
affect politics
does politics even matter anymore is all
of politics
conspiratorial um just in the sense of
you know conspire i mean i haven't
checked this out but
in latin it sounds to me like breathing
together
probably interpreted as whispering
together or something like that
so what is this behind the scenes force
and if we actually decided matt you
weren't here but we decided last week
that we were a leftist
podcast so if we're looking forward
[Laughter]
if we're looking forward to dealing with
conspiracy theory what would that look
like
um as a as a negotiation
but we're a big tent leftist uh
leftist podcast aren't we i mean i think
uh it's nice to have you here matt
because i feel like you and i are both
what the rest of them would call just
libs we are anti-pedophile though that's
that's a we're not we're not breaking on
that point but you guys do welcome
left-handed we don't like anime no anime
here either
open the hentai though
[Laughter]
plastic pills does not endorse this
opinion
um but yeah i was actually thinking
about the way in which
in terms of what's happening with the
republican party in politics right now
like
what's interesting is yeah there's a lot
of conspiracy theories emerging but it's
also kind of
and i wonder what matt thinks about this
that like i feel like in some ways the
alt-right
and a certain brand of like conspiracy
theories have now
like don't really know what to do
because like their their narratives
aren't working anymore
in like uh in like the covid context
like i feel like we hear a lot more
or we hear a lot less from like sort of
identity based conspiracy thinking i
feel like the alt-right's been
like hasn't been very active lately at
least not that i've noticed maybe maybe
they are just as active but i just
i feel like there's a way in which now
like certain kinds of narratives about
what's
happening and like that there's like a
left-wing conspiracy
like they try to use these but
like the reality of kovid
just prevents like it only allows it to
go so far
i don't know yeah i know i've talked
about that before right and
i think it's too early to talk about
whether this is going to undermine
figures like trump or other right-wing
foreign conspiracy theorizing
since i don't want to make those
predictions since i made those kind of
predictions
back in 2016 saying that trump wasn't
going to be elected and obviously that's
what happened right
but i do think that the kovic crisis
does demonstrate
the limits of a post-modern approach to
politics like the one that people like
trump endorsed
uh precisely because death is about as
real as it gets for most people exactly
and you can't talk your way past it you
can't bs your way through it
and because people have a very
fundamental and genetic anxiety towards
it exactly there's
uh now this doesn't mean people won't
attempt to do that uh and
we see that they've tried to make all
kinds of efforts to do so but whether
the public in general
is going to swallow it outside of a
small hardcore
trump supporters you know maybe 40 or so
i mean that's an open question and we've
seen trump's poll numbers dropping
uh pretty quickly over the last couple
weeks so it doesn't seem like that's
really
sticking uh the way that they would want
it to yeah i mean it's it's fascinating
the way we've also seen him
lately have this kind of double message
this contradictory message i mean trump
i mean where he's
you know on the one hand he's he has
guidelines about when states can open up
but then on the next on the other hand
he's saying like liberate
whatever state liberate michigan uh like
supporting the protesters there who are
kind of saying
they want to reopen uh and i don't know
like like i was
when we were having the broader
discussion about conspiracy theories i
was kind of like thinking about
like when it does when like because i
feel like there's a lot of
conspiratorial language that isn't like
like a full-out conspiracy theory on the
right like about that the left kind of
wants to keep things closed and it's not
quite a conspiracy theory but there's
like some
conspiratorial flirting from like you
hear from people like laura ingram on
fox news and
yeah i just feel like there's there's
this kind of like you know oh they don't
want us to open they don't want you to
to like go back to work you know they
want to keep you
uh in in in in lockdown for whatever
reason because they want to demonstrate
the the like
i don't know social welfare programs or
who knows what it is i don't know
yeah well i think this is part and
parcel of the kind of hyper masculist
dialogue that you see
on the political right particularly the
american political right today
and you know how they say the opposite
of love isn't hatred it's indifference
right because
uh both of these are strong feelings
right uh the opposite
of bluster isn't um you know
kind of quiet self-control uh it's
paranoia right right
uh and so oh sorry don't the inverse of
bluster's paranoia and i think that's
what you're seeing right now the
dialectic
between paranoia and bluster on trump's
part where on the one hand
he wants to present himself and his
followers as being
strong and assertive and they're not
going to take it and they're going to
fight back against the system that
oppresses them even though trump is the
system now
but on the other hand in order to make
that meaningful there has to be
something that they're afraid of
otherwise they're just protesting
against nothing that's all that
threatening yeah
so the other side of this is of course
to present corona as a very real threat
something that's extremely dangerous
uh that it's been produced by the usa's
mortal enemy to try to undermine them
and this is obviously a contradictory
message right
but it's a necessary dialectic between
bluster and paranoia that trump's been
carrying on throughout the course of his
presidency
uh and i don't know if it's all going to
work in these kinds of circumstances
precisely because like as we were
talking about death is a very real thing
uh that people tend to not be paranoid
about they tend to be genuinely afraid
of it
right with good reason um and whether
that's gonna
undermine his support or the support of
other people like him i don't know but i
certainly hope so yeah
bring on you know uh if we can't have
democratic socialism because bernie
sanders is in the race at least let's
have
reform liberalism i mean in a way in a
way it's great to have uh
matthew with us today considering he is
in the sort of uh
left-wing uh the the right-wing
outreach department of the left
and today the the the prevailing wisdom
of uh of looking at at conspiracy
theories is that we we shouldn't dismiss
these people who believe in them as
paranoia acts we shouldn't dismiss them
in that way because that
often just drives them into a more
hardline belief right if we
i mean what i tend to do and i'm sure
what tons of other people to do is
if i'm arguing with some nut job on the
internet i tend to just dismiss them i
just say [ __ ] off buddy
and i don't want anything to do with it
or i see a conspiracy theory and i know
it right away and i give it no credence
but that way of thinking is also
the way of thinking that reinforces
people's sort of let's say maladaptive
views and it's really important to try
to reach out to these people
and even before they adopt conspiracy
theories just
just to say hey you know like
anti-vaxxers right like before they
become anti-vaxxers let's give them
information about vaccines or become
before they become flat earthers like
give them a globe that is filled with
whiskey
and then they'll see that the world is
round and there's liquor inside of it
and everything's okay
or something like that right like like
that's where we need to be and that's
always the
i mean i i think of the lacanian
perspective all the time because he's
always coming up with this
idea of paranoiac that was one of his
first
sort of big ideas right uh but
but that comes with the connotations of
you're just paranoid
right you're just believing something
that's not true because of some kind of
psychological defect
and that's the way you reinforce
people's
hurtful beliefs right that's not the way
you actually are supposed to engage with
these kinds of people yeah absolutely
and i mean i think this demonstrates the
need to actually
resuscitate but alter um the old niching
category of resentment
as a kind of political emotion and i
think wendy brown's done a good job of
this in a recent book
in the ruins of neoliberalism when she
kind of talks about how it is that
resentment doesn't necessarily have to
be resentment of the weak
towards the powerful the way nietzsche
was talking about resentment can also be
uh the feeling that people have if they
are powerful and they don't want to give
up that power and they feel that their
entitlement to it is being undermined
by people from below which is exactly
what you're seeing happen
with the trump phenomena and i think
this is why people on the left have
really struggled with actually
addressing these individuals in a way
that gets them to change their mind
because when you constantly tell them
you know you're powerful you should give
up some of that
to create a more equal and harmonious
society it generates these extremely
strong feelings of resentment
that most of us would say they're not
entitled to since what they're they have
a privileged position
but it is resentment nonetheless right
and
talking to them as if they're just
paranoid and
conspiratorial and they don't really
understand what's going on just stops
this kind of attitude right and of
course and i'm not exactly sure how to
get rid of that i like how to move past
that and of course
and of course one way in which uh they
they hear they hear uh like
a leftist talking to them about
something like privilege
sometimes in their ears it sounds like
the leftist person as the conspiracy
theorist right talking about this
you know like white privilege is some i
don't know some force
in the air that you know determines
everything so like that's one of the
ways in which i think it's uh it can be
counterproductive because it's
the left is still sound like they're
falling into a different brand of
conspiracy thinking
and i don't want to take us backwards
but just because
i think based on my channel views
some people actually read the khan
lakhan's paranoiac
is not someone who is paranoid the
laconia the acadian paranoia is someone
who
over determines the role of the big
other the big other of course doesn't
exist
it's part of you but you over determine
the view of yourself as if
from outside which is what makes you a
paranoiac and that is
not partial to right or left politics in
any way yeah
yeah i had this a potential lacanian
approach that you guys have kind of
got me wondering about especially eric
and matt
so um you know eric you brought up a
couple approaches for how to
you know talk to people i mean education
of course uh early on
um now what separates lacan
apart from a lot of analysts is he does
not want to take a part in the discourse
the analyst's
position is a little bit like the
hysterics to
the last time
we lost him again this is the conspiracy
theory in action right now
right the powers that be are prevented
they're shutting us down because they
know he'll understand
the physical materiality of the big
other wishes
alex not to dispense his wisdom
absolutely
yeah does anyone know what he was going
to say
can you guys hear me yeah i can hear you
now yeah yes can you hear me
okay matt brought up how
basically in the absence of a big other
uh or god you know we have to posit a
new one
so um do you think we could take an
analytic approach
to these theorists and constantly ask
questions until
they realize they are using their
imagination
so much or leaping into contradiction is
this
uh position a way that we could actually
create dialogue that would you know
open up to i
i personally don't think so right and i
mean one of the reasons is that
conservativism is fundamentally a
disposition more than it is a thought
out theory
it rationalizes various ways of looking
at the world in a hierarchical manner
after the fact which is why it's always
retrospective
right and the problem with trying to get
somebody who's dispositionally inclined
towards certain conservative positions
to change whether because of education
or by constantly questioning what
they're doing and
my experience at least and maybe people
will find a different one
is then they'll eventually just throw
out their hands and say well what else
am i supposed to believe in then
right and then if anything you'll
entrench
their desire to support these kinds of
other like these kinds of systems of
meaning if you want uh because
now not only do they realize that they
can latch on to nothing else
but they feel like you're an antagonist
who's deliberately trying to separate
themselves
from something that gave them a great
deal of significance in their life and
it's important to politically
marginalize you
because now you pose a threat right and
that's a paranoiac
in the most embodied sense of it they're
saying
if you take away these you know whatever
amorphous values
you must give me a big other because if
you take away my big other
then i have no possible function
in the universe whereas i think most of
us have realized already
you know who who the [ __ ] cares
no i mean they killed socrates right so
i mean i think that's exactly the point
right you know
you leave euthyphro without beliefs in
the gods and then yeah five days later
he's going to be casting a stone into a
pot saying yeah let them drink the
hemlock right
i think it could work you know if you
have friends or if you wanted to spend
all day on the internet asking more and
more and make people realize they don't
know
as much as they're claiming to i think
it could potentially
be a way to you know
help us you know pull out of this kind
of thinking because it is getting
a lot of traction but it would be
time-consuming
i think so and i mean like i've i've
convinced a few people to change their
minds and some people have written to me
saying like
blah blah thank you which is always nice
to hear and i'm not saying that to kind
of
brag i'm just trying to say this is a
very very rare thing right and
you i think you should brag if you've
changed people's minds you sure
you're taking shots in the dark okay but
the point that i was trying to get at is
this was not i mean alex is right it was
a very long process and not only is it a
very long process it's an
individuated process right like you have
to talk to people like individuals speak
to their interests
intelligently and with some air addition
and then you kind of have to work them
through why it is that they don't need
to lean
on these systems of meaning uh but they
can if you want to put it very
colloquially just think for themselves
right uh and there's no formula for this
and because there is no formula for it
well what if there was a common
formula for this i mean if if this is a
goal that we could have societally
and i would pay you a lot of money and i
would i pay you a lot of money to get
that because you'd make my life a lot
easier so give it to me yeah how did it
did it work with uh stefan mullin you no
yeah yeah absolutely he's just he
brought to me afterwards and he's like
i've become
[Music]
[Laughter]
well matt recently has a patreon up but
i think
we should support him as the uh outreach
wing yeah because he's saying that i'm
going to function as the analyst
for the left wing to the right wing
which is something that i
have absolutely no patience at all yeah
it takes monumental patience for that
sort of thing
yeah remember when when remember when we
met that alt-right guy who was from
california
plastic fills on oh don't don't talk
about it
[Laughter]
[Music]
no okay early in the night well i'll
just give you a summary early in the
night
he threatened to fight me and if you saw
this guy
no it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
early in the night he threatened to
fight me
and then later in the night he was
crying on my
shoulder after having a few shots of
whatever he was drinking
saying i just wanted a community
that's all i wanted yeah
no he's he's the paradigmatic
jordan peterson patriarch he is
to be
they'll cry on her shoulder you know
here's my last thought
could we make better leftist conspiracy
theories
better leftist conspiracy theories
i'm intrigued what do you mean
i'm intrigued by this too i'm actually
tempted to say that plastic pills have
to
have some kind of conspiratorial element
to it because when i first saw your
symbol
what the [ __ ] does that mean how can i
join yeah
it's a very matrix who would want to
take a plastic pill anyway
yeah oh well they're fake all right
they're not real false consciousness
and ideology critique is a left-wing
conspiracy theory
and that's exactly what well not exactly
but that's what agon
was applying to kovid he had this
rough and ready theory and he applied it
and
it had disastrous results and he's still
writing articles he just wrote one like
a few days ago didn't he
trying to yeah i think i linked one i
linked like a little short thing to you
guys
if you did yeah and just trying to
clarify like why he's stupid or
something like that i didn't actually
read it but
but false consciousness when you claim
that people are
voting against their interests or
believing in things that are harmful to
them
you just claim that they have false
consciousness and that they should be
doing something better
they should have some kind of class
solidarity that seems to me like a
conspiracy theory because it just
seems to say that there's a ruling class
that
has this unified set of interests that
they're just opposing on
everyone underneath them no that was
never said
was that we take on the beliefs of those
we identify with
and you identify with who you want to be
or become
so but they're identifying with the
wrong people they're identifying with
those
in power and they're eating out of their
hands when they should be identifying
with
each other solidarity
educators with educators that's not the
point that's not at the point
i'm gonna like just stand by eric here
for a few seconds and just say that
i get what he's saying right too often
the left kind of leans on theories of
false consciousness
to kind of wash away any responsibility
uh for failing to actually mobilize
people to support their policies right
i saw a lot of that after jeremy corbyn
was defeated you know it's not anything
that we did because
our policies were perfect our man was
perfect uh
you know the situation call for election
reforms the reason is you know the
right-wing machine convince people to
vote against their class
interests or whatever it happens to be
same with sanders i think that's the
kind of
yeah i know exactly right and i think
that's the kind of lazy theorizing
that we can't use right now because it's
all too easy to say it's not our fault
nothing we do
uh it's just this gigantic right-wing
machine that's always going to bully us
into submission
by brainwashing our supporters but i
think it's true in the same way i think
conspiracy theories are true
it takes that that kernel of truth right
there's that kernel of truth there
and then there's this apparatus of
deception built around it that
is untrue or that extends it beyond
all sensibility whatsoever well i think
where it's not true is like i think it
over determines
this idea that like human beings want to
be have solidarity and maybe is ignoring
the truth that that there is something
in human in in human being that wants to
uh
like look to authority or there's like
at least a temptation in human beings to
look towards authority and that's like
uh
maybe inconvenient truth or leftist
solidarity
who seems like they're getting
everything they desire
and identifying with that remind i want
to remind you when mark's
exactly was the one who brought up this
idea from the very beginning
that you know the proletariat is
identifying with the beliefs of the
bourgeoisie it's not just about like
party politics it's about like you know
all the people going out and buying
things who are broke and can't afford it
but buy it just so they don't look
poor it's because they think they're
going to get the objects of their desire
if they
buy the commodity fetishes so it's not
just about
you know identifying with authority it's
about saying that's someone who's
getting what they want
how can i be that or at least look like
that
so it's about you know desire class and
you know it's not just about
taking on beliefs because we were told
to
i mean it's not all about that because
like i mean celebrities are the people
who get
everything they want and they've got to
be [ __ ] careful right now because
people are if they complain about what
they have to do for kovid right people
are going to [ __ ] all over them
like look at that video that came out
recently they were all singing
uh imagine all the people and they they
got
[ __ ] on because they are completely
disconnected with the average person's
struggle in this situation they get
everything they want
but we don't want them to get whatever
they want if they're going to
be these disconnected tools yeah we wish
we were them
well i can tell this is going to be a
[ __ ] to edit yeah
i'm like three beers deep now i'm
running in all directions
[Laughter]
so we've discussed this from several
different dimensions
and dealt with you know what people are
what people think they are what people
wish they were
um all as part of conspiracy theory and
it's really all connected i would like
to actually
point out that i've came here for
conspiratorial reasons
and part of it was to talk about my book
that's released tomorrow
okay i just thought it'd be funny to do
that no
we're gonna get to that at the end i
mean
the rest of you and then we're gonna go
i'm gonna introduce matt
and give him his yeah his second matt's
his uh matt's book plug zone plug zone
no i got
i got nothing i don't know
all right i will just come out to say
then
that i think conspiracy theories
are insanely creative and they're
fun just because they're so much better
to be creative
and write about stuff than it is to just
be creative and
wrong about everything though isn't that
better can't you write fiction
well that is what you're doing picking
up on plastic pills is point
i would say that uh i think
like maybe one thing we haven't really
like
acknowledged it's just that well yes
conspiracy theories provide this kind of
sense of security maybe like a kind of
ontological stability or like the oh in
over determining reality but then like
just picking up on what plastic pills
are saying like
it's true that they're just also just
the fact that they're more fun
and that like non-conspiracy theories
are boring
and it's like maybe that's one part of
it that is uh
maybe not an insignificant reason for
their
reality is boring this is actually one
thing that i was really disappointed by
because
i felt like we should have talked about
philip k dick since pretty much
all of his novels are precisely about
all these themes big conspiracies and
trapping the little man who's concerned
about whether god exists and whether
he's real and so on
and never once did his name why didn't
you bring it up till now
i was going to but then my computer
[ __ ] up okay the powers that be
interfere with me also just like they
interfere with alex
yeah i don't know how does that be i'll
figure it out this is very lovecraftian
too you could talk about that too
dick lovecraft the the fringe
bernie bros probably have some theories
about
the powers that were working against
sanders
they're they're conspiracy theories
whether or not they're true
yeah and aren't there and not all
conspiracy theories aren't true
some of them are guys it's a matter of
time
all right so we have covered
a lot of ground here it was organic i
really actually liked what we did here
do you guys like that
just like giving a topic and then i
enjoyed it
kind of bouncing off each other i think
that's a good sign
anyways i want to thank our guest
sort of guest matt mcmanus
a refugee from mexico
[Laughter]
you can find him on twitter at poll
or at matt pull prof
he also has two books out and there's
something new coming out matt what is
that
uh yeah so our book myth and mayhem a
leftist critique of jordan peterson
is out tomorrow uh it is written by me
marian trejo conrad hamilton ben burgess
and g-jek introduces the book so
we can't say tomorrow because who knows
when this is going to be done yeah say
the date
oh it's being released may or april 24th
and matt also has a
patreon patreon
hey chan how do you no i was like that
was a question
it was a it was a poorly phrased
question
if you like what i'm doing uh yeah if
you like what you're doing you can read
any of my articles on outlets like ariel
marion west
uh or art digital and i also have a
patreon page set up that has some
exclusive content that people might want
to see
and you can always yell at them on
facebook
do you absolutely do you have a lot of
patreon supporters man i'm curious
uh i got a few like i have seven now and
i'm making forty dollars a month
and that was in a day so i'm relatively
happy with that
it means i can buy like beer for one
night
so matt is a friend of the show
definitely going to come on
again at some point hopefully
oh yeah do it i don't know this is
just going to be a mess to edit because
i don't know what what parts are
narrative i don't want to
bring in matt's patreon viewers as part
of it
why not maybe we'll pay walls so
we can pay wall some of this and uh make
some money
yeah we could be like find out about
matt's patreon hey wallet halfway
through
by the way yeah okay yeah i was gonna
ask another question
well put on the bit about matt's patreon
um
and after that all right
so the last thing we have to do
everybody gets to say
one word before we shut this down what
and we're gonna start
with matt who's patreon we're supporting
d'souza all right politics guy
uh power structure i guess that's two
words
i don't know this is stupid why is this
aggression
semi artists and since i'm the host i
don't have to say anything so this is
plastic pills
thanks for listening that's [ __ ]
take care of yourselves don't breathe in
covet
suck a tailpipe all right that's a wrap
stop recording
i'm gonna start turning it off
[Music]
you